[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce 7,8
culture un magazine un peu particulier
pendant 26 minutes nous reviendrons sur
les saisons 2018-2019 des précédents
magazine et on parlera de plusieurs
salles saint-quentinoise on démarre tout
de suite avec la scène nationale
le théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
qui propose 56 spectacle pour autant de
découvertes des voyages où vous pourrez
partir très loin de chez vous ou
découvrir vos voisins des spectacles
surprenants à découvrir dès le 29
septembre de la directrice adjointe
cette saison qu'est ce que ça nous
réserve des voyages des femmes à des
voyages des femmes à travers ça on peut
dire pour simplifier une très grande
ouverture aux autres et une très grande
ouverture au monde en restant près de
chez soi c'est le plaisir du spectateur
que de voyager tout en restant ainsi
comment est ce qu'elle est pensée
cette saison il ya une un thème un fil
rouge et pas de fil rouge mais il ya le
souci de créer des équilibres
déséquilibre entre eux ce qui vient de
loin et ce qui vient d'ici
déséquilibre entre ce qui relève de la
culture classique beaucoup de gens font
leurs premiers pas de spectateurs en
venant découvrir des grands auteurs
classiques des grands textes classiques
du répertoire de théâtre d'autres sont
plus curieux souhaitent découvrir des
voix venues du monde où des formes
théâtrales qui requiert de nouvelles
technologies ou qu'ils inventent des
dramaturgies un petit peu différente de
celle qu'on a l'habitude de voir
donc nous on travaille avec le désir et
l'envié de donner à voir des palettes
les plus larges possibles
il ya effectivement pas mal de femmes
dans cette
saison 2018 2019 soit en tant que
créatrice parce qu'un beaucoup de fermes
dans le monde artistique qui sont des
créatrices de talent on a aussi beaucoup
de voix de femmes
qui traverse toute la saison il ya du
jazz il ya de la musique africaine vous
fait voyager
il ya aussi un spectacle
particulièrement qui est le disent les
10 et 11 octobre et l'ailleurs de
l'autre voulait qu'un voyage très très
loin voyage entre louis alors en voyage
à travers les techniques vocales puisque
les quatre chanteuses de ce spectacle
appartiennent à l'ensemble vocal les
cris de paris dirigé par geoffroy
jourdain et geoffroy jourdain à quelques
années à a mis la main sur des
échantillons sonores venus du monde
entier notamment des chants des chants
de femmes des perceuses des appels au
recueillement
des appels à la halacha malick faye oui
à quelque chose d'un peu magique et
d'assez spirituel dans tous ces chants
qui l'a recueillie en a fait un
spectacle avec l'aide de d'aliénor
douchez qui est une pareille jeunes
femmes metteurs en scène très
prometteuse est très intéressante et là
on est vraiment dans des voix lyrique
qui essayent de s'emparer d'un
répertoire qui n'est pas du tout le leur
avec pas de partition des techniques
vocales qui sont radicalement
différentes donc il faut se réinventer
m
[Musique]
et
des 10 km à montigny le bretonneux la
saison débute en musique avec amira la
commune a concocté une saison 2018-2019
éclectique elle devrait ravir les petits
mais aussi les grands
un conseil accrochez vous extraits
trente sept rendez vous à ne pas manquer
en essayant de mettre en place une
saison comme on le fait tous les ans qui
puisse répondre à tous les goûts à
toutes les envies
autour comme vous le disiez de la
musique du théâtre
des spectacles variés une combinaison
très éclectique de tout ce qui se trouve
sur paris et qu'on arrive quand même à
ramener surmonté de nombreux tonneaux et
justement ça commence en musique avant
tout et on met les pieds dans le plat
dès le 6 octobre sept amir qui ouvre la
saison une belle date une belle date une
ouverture avec i'm here on s'efforce
toujours de faire une ouverture qui soit
marquantes
je crois que là on a marqué un grand
coup amir qui sort d'une d'une tournée
avec 250 dates dans toute la france et
qui a affiché complet sur trois dates
parisiennes
un deuxième album un concert debout qui
est prévu on attend 1500 personnes
donc c'est effectivement un rendez vous
à ne pas manquer
là
le ton
c'est un eye a aussi une belle place
pour l'humour ya manu payet le 13
octobre à m sila le 10 novembre
chris esquerre le 29 janvier ou même
caroline vigneaux de 9 avril
forero c'est oui vas fous rires pour
toutes ces personnes qui viennent nous
rendre visite alors pour reprendre
rapidement un petit peu les noms que
vous avez cités dont caroline vidéo est
une fidèle c'est pas la première fois
qu'on la sueur sur notre ville c'est son
nouveau spectacle c'est son meilleur
spectacle est effectivement manu payet
va je crois que c'était aussi une
opportunité à saisir
on sait on connaît sa carrière à la fois
dans le milieu du cinéma mais aussi dans
un cadre d'humour et puis je ne sais
plus des deux autres experts à m sila
même s'il est qui grimpe à m sila qui
grimpe qui grimpe et à tous les niveaux
il a aussi qu'il est aussi débuter une
carrière cinématographique et puis chris
esquerre qui lui bon voilà ancien
chroniqueur sur france inter deuxième
spectacle un humour très décalé donc
tout aussi intéressant à voir la salle
jacques brel et les têtes d'affiché
c'est pas ça ne s'est pas seulement dans
l'humour c'est aussi au théâtre
sept jours de citer tout le monde
barbara schulz ariel mal et charles
berling jean pierre darroussin il ya du
jane birkin gossip qui déclare à nouveau
son amour à gainsbourg
ouais vous visez très large jane birkin
ou effectivement mais jane birkin doit
déclarer son amour à gainsbourg durant
toute sa carrière 1 et je crois que là
c'est un véritable hommage
elle est accompagnée par l'orchestré
lamoureux qui est très très grand
symphonique 1
et puis a effectivement elle revisite
tout le répertoire de serge gainsbourg
donc une une grande et belle soirée à la
ferme du manège
de vous à moi
bisous
mon amour éclectisme et diversité c'est
aussi du côté de plaisir le théâtre
espace coluche et donner un mot d'ordre
vous faire venir au théâtre et plus de
30 rendez vous sont ainsi programmés
écouter chez vous la saison débute avec
de l'humour celui de karim duval
oui alors je lis moi je ne connaissais
pas je les ai découverts à avignon vive
le festival d'avignon off ça c'est
vraiment le spectacle de lancement de
saison
dans le temps on avait des créations
diana fait plus difficile en avoir
maintenant donc moi j'essaie de de faire
découvrir mes coups de coeur j'allais
dire d'avignon sur un spectacle gratuit
de lancement de saison qui nous permet
aussi de relancer le public pour leur
dire ben voilà venez venez au théâtre il
ya plein de beaux spectacles sa
causticité
sans être méchant parce que l'humour
vache comme l'amour vache d'ailleurs
c'est pas bien avec l' île et ça pique
un s'applique quand il envoie des vannes
parfois mais c'est pas méchant
et donc c'est très drôle
[Musique]
rien de scientifique
ce qui marque aussi sur votre saison
c'est la place à la musique et de toutes
les musiques toutes les musiques
oui c'est bien que vous me lancer sur
toutes les musiques parce que ça va être
michel jonasz ils savent être aussi
celle à qui revient sur scène
moi j'étais allé la voir au casino de
paris mais bon comme celle là mais
c'était génial parce qu'elle s'est fait
accompagné d'un groupe qui s'appelle le
groupe hashtag elle est devenue très
rock et c'est fait ça passe très très
bien
et puis on a aussi plaza francia
orchestra qui est je ne sais pas si vous
avez eu le temps de remarquer que ces
anciennement gotan project
donc c'est quand même très haut niveau
voilà et on a du flamenco on a de la
musique gitane respect du gospel pour
ouvrir la saison aussi et vont profiter
de cette grande salle est cette grande
scène vous faites aussi de la poésie
musicale est alors grand écart aux
comédies musicales des vastes mois le
livre de la jungle
hier il ya la photo leïla pour tous les
goûts alors des vastes mois en plus
c'est intéressant c'est dans le cadre du
festival sur le handicap qui le festival
qui s'appelait anciennement au rhdp qui
s'appelle imago maintenant des vastes
moi c'est avec emmanuel laborie molière
quand même
mais pas n'importe quelle comédienne et
tom sawyer et ben voilà on passe de
dévaster mois une création à tom sawyer
qui est une création aussi mais moins
contemporain qui est gelée vu aussi un
pari en fait ils sont les spectacles au
programme je les vois pas ce que je suis
non c'est pas intéressant et c'est
vraiment très très bien fait c'est très
très bien fait donc ça s'appelait
vraiment à tous les enfants sachant que
le livre de la jungle
ce n'est pas la partition de walt disney
forcément ça a été réécrit et c'est le
spectacle qui refaire par la ville aux
enfants scolarisés à plaisir à
guyancourt à la ferme de bel ébat le
public va découvrir un mot qu'on connaît
peu le matrimoine et pourtant il va
rythmer la saison de la salle guyancourt
toise 2018 2019 yoann lavabre il dévoile
quelques secrets
alors cette année la ferme innove avec
un projet autour du matrimoine avec
aurore et 20 matrimoine tout à fait le
matrimoine c'est
un mot étrange parce que c'est un mot
qui sonne comme un néologisme alors
qu'en réalité c'est un mot très anciens
on parlait au moyen âge on avait le
patrimoine c'est est-ce que ce que le ce
que le mari a mené aux ménages et le
matrimoine c'est est-ce que ce que la
femme apportait on n'a gardé que le mot
patrimoine en a d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
des journées européennes du patrimoine
d'un côté et puis les des agences
matrimoniales de l'autre ça en dit
beaucoup sur sur la façon dont les mots
qu'on utilise
est ce que c'est ce que s'exprime le
matrimoine donc c'est en fait c'est
l'héritage l'héritage des mères c'est ce
qui nous vient des femmes à travers
l'histoire donc la ferme de bel ébat
effectivement s'engage pour la saison
prochaine et les quatre suivantes 1
c'est un grand un grand projet à
valoriser cet héritage artistique et
culturelle féminin tant dans le domaine
du théâtre que dans le domaine de la
musique
donc on va favoriser la programmation de
pièces écrites par des femmes au 17e 18e
19e siècle pareil pour la musique et
avec des femmes aussi sur scène il n'y
en a pas mal oui c'est que la ferme de
bel bat s'est engagé depuis 2012 dans
une programmation paritaire afin de
respecter les équilibres entre les
femmes et les hommes dans la création
artistique
hélas le matrimoine c'est allez encore
un petit peu au-delà cirque c'est un peu
plonger dans les racines de l'histoire
du théâtre pour pour ré offrir une
légitimité aux femmes artistes
d'aujourd'hui parce que c'est ce qui
manque un petit peu on ne connaît pas
les autres is des siècles passés
et pourtant ce sont de très belles
plumes je rappelle pendant que le favori
de madame de villedieu qui va ouvrir le
ce cycle sur le patrimoine qui a été
créé à la ferme de bel ébat en 2015
voilà c'est une pièce que nous reprenons
et cette pièce a été mise en scène en
1665 par un homme qui n'est pas tout à
fait un inconnu dans l'histoire du
théâtre puisque cet homme s'appelait
molière la molière avait monté le fameux
nuit
de madame de villedieu et la pièce avait
joué à versailles pratiquement à
l'inauguration de versailles devant le
donc ces pièces étaient tout à fait à
l'honneur à l'époque elles sont
aujourd'hui oubliées et on a on a pour
ambition de les faire redécouvrir
voilà comment le théâtre français n'ont
qu'à nous paraît se disent prêts à
partager aux autres
moi le prisme vise aussi la culture pour
tous avec du choix du rire du jazz
records du théâtre et c'est aussi la
première saison
entièrement programmée par la ville
d'elancourt un mot de sa nouvelle
directrice virginie marceau dans la
continuité du travail réalisé au prisme
depuis des années on est sur une
programmation voilà qui propose à la
fois du théâtre de la musique de la
danse pour toutes les tranches d'âge et
tous les publics la culture pour tous
tout à fait c'est je sais de toute façon
credo de
cette nouvelle programmation et puis
tous les arméniens et grecs trop j'ai
aussi tel qu'il a été imaginé dès le
départ en mai dans cette intimité de
travail cherchez-vous la saison débute
le 12 octobre et c'est un duo qui monte
oui elles reviennent d'une tournée de
deux ans à l'international et bélie ce
sont deux soeurs à la musique très
métissée oui ebayi et deux soeurs
jumelles puisqu'il pays signifie
également jumelles en l'an mil yoruba
qui est la langue en fait des esclaves
noirs déplacer à cuba ce sont les deux
filles d'un percussionniste du buena
vista social club
on peut de ligré intéressant et en fait
elles ont connu voilà une carrière assez
fulgurante premier album en 2015 une
tournée mondiale des parrainages voilà
comme prinze donc voilà une trajectoire
assez un problème elles sont sûres un
métissage musical entre la soul electro
les musiques traditionnelles à elles
sortent un deuxième album file en sortie
d'ailleurs déjà qui s'intitule h
donc on les accueille dans le cadre de
cette nouvelle tournée et puis elles
viennent au prisme donc pour l'ouverture
de saison ce sera le premier spectacle
de la saison
en configuration grande salle assis
debout parce qu'on est sûr des concerts
musiques actuelles plutôt festif avec la
possibilité aussi des traces immanente
[Musique]
au crâne j'ai plus peur
the wash moussa sow
dans votre programmation il ya aussi des
têtes d'affiché on pourra pas toutes les
citer général elektriks eric métayer
lionnel astier frédéric bouraly qu'on
connaît surtout sur une sur une série
manu payet
arthur ashe c'est pareil on ouvre large
oui on ouvre large et dans tous les
champs artistiques puisqu'à la fois aux
musiques actuelles on vient de l'évoquer
avec ribéry arthur ashe je pense que
voilà beaucoup le connaissent avec un
dixième album qui est assez merveilleux
qui s'intitule amour chien flou double
album dédié à l'amour sous toutes ses
formes
on accueillera également bon qu'à saison
prochaine j'ai plus tout à fait les
dates en tête mais voilà vous avez
exactement
arthur ashe dans le champ du théâtre
donc vous l'avez cité eric métayer la
leçon danse mais aussi avec mettez y
andré bascou de masse qu'on voit là il
en faudrait pour les chatouille les
chatouilles voilà au préalable qu'ils
étaient voilà une adaptation d'un jeu là
un peu de parcours de vendre et à brice
pont et puis là on est dans un registre
est différent une comédie romantique
sensible une ode à l'humanité de
personnalités complètement improbable
qu'ils vont se croiser une danseuse
blessé un scientifique aussi autiste qui
ne supporte pas qu'on le touche
et puis voilà ils vont se croiser pour
une leçon de danse et voilà de ça va
naître voilà une relation assez
incroyable pour terminer ce tour
d'horizon direction la ville de trappes
et sa salle de spectacle la merise une
saison placée sous le signe de la
jeunesse alors si les enfants sont à
l'honneur les grands ne sont pas oubliés
des artistes reviennent sur le devant de
la scène avec deux nouveaux albums
extrait à la merise cette saison vous
lisez sur les jeunes et la jeunesse oui
on va dire ça mais il y en a un peu pour
tous les agents va dire je préfère dire
ça donc les structures pluri
générationnel on a pensé à tout le monde
voilà
après la mise en avant oui sur certaines
dates à ses clés où on avait des
formules contre on met en avant pour les
plus jeunes notamment en avoir parlé de
ce cru tous que ça c'est votre première
avec les plus jeunes mais qui vont faire
aussi révélé plus grand avec des rêves
un peu sable et des rêves dans le sable
exactement oui donc c'est lawrence
durrell qui a qui nous ouvre la saison
ici donc prouver ce qu'ils savent pas ou
qui connaissent pas c'est quelqu'un qui
dessine sur un vidéoprojecteur est donc
toute l'histoire prend forme avec un
fard la régie de ses mains et
automatiquement donc est elle dresse
tient l'ensemble de tous ces différents
tableaux au fur et à mesure la force le
spectacle est bien sûr la lecture des
histoires
vous accordez aussi une très belle place
à la musique alors il ya des noms qu'on
les présente plus disiz la peste moi
c'est mon adolescence être us tiken jah
fakoly et dialysés pour les militantes
une certaine o'shea à auchy oui bah oui
c'est un pied d'étoilé montante on va
dire ça je sais tout bête il ya un an
moi je travaille par le tourneur et puis
on dit on a une super fille qui vient de
ton coin donc cher beau et j'ai écouté
j'ai toujours être tout de suite été
emballé par dieu parle à sa fougue sa
jeunesse est également l amène quelque
chose de frais il ya là un timbre vocal
qui est hyper intéressant c'est donc là
je dirais banco affaire intéresse c'est
une jeune artiste voilà en plus c'est
local et caetera et puis donc voilà et
entre temps c'est une artiste qui vit
voilà un autre titre est sorti c'est
la marinière et puis ça passe bien à la
télé à la radio ça passe un peu partout
et on est très content
[Musique]
jetés à la mer
et à bouffer aux boissons
le poison d'avril
les boues pas d'inquiétude
elle disait sur les cons
trust démodables après il ya des sorties
d'albums donc 10 sera l'album donc
là un film vient de sortir donc c'est un
début de tournée donc voilà c'est un peu
la date en est un rap week-end musiques
musiques urbaines à la brise puisque le
vendredi on aura dix et le lendemain à
battle donc des bboy france une demi
finale
donc voilà on fait un peu un clin d'oeil
aux cultures urbaines
voilà le meurice on mélange un peu tout
les talents et et tout le monde a sa
place là on paraître trust we trust
c'est paris c'est un vieux groupe de
rock qui s'est reformé et puis avec une
sortie d'album au nom de la rage qui
doivent très très bien et c'était ouais
on se fait longtemps qu'on était dessus
on voulait un groupe de rock et va on
est très content en tout cas les
accueillir et puis ça s'apprend ils ont
accepté ça sera en plus la seule date en
ile-de-france dont on est très content
et tous est entre tous ces entretiens
sont à retrouver dans leur globalité sur
notre site internet tv 78 points comme
un petit un petit détour du côté des
précédentes émissions du cetud culture
et vous êtes sûr de ne rien rater
certaines communes et salle attendre la
rentrée pour vous dévoiler leur rendez
vous et c'est notamment le cas de
maurepas vous pouvez noter dans votre
agenda la date du 22 septembre pour
découvrir les autres saisons les autres
salles saint-quentinoise incite à
retenir cas ce que pense qu'ils point fr
et pour patienter un peu avant la
reprise des spectacles pourquoi ne pas
profiter du cinéma en plein air parce
que à partir du 18 août 20h45 seller qui
lance les projections du rendez vous
départemental
et puis j'ai envie de saint-quentinoise
vous attendent alors à elancourt laissez
vous tenter par jurassic world à
guyancourt ce sera l'âge de glace et à
plaisir vous pourrez redécouvrir sully
de clint eastwood avec tom hanks
mais c'est à montigny le bretonneux que
ça commence avec un film familial le
troisième volet des aventures de groulx
et des millions extraits
qe3 de montrer mon frère
des mercato mais tu ferais mieux avec
tes cheveux là il n'est pas content vous
devez être sa merveilleuse épouse
charmeur s'étendre et impressionnant moi
c'est pas mal je ne lâche pas vraiment
d'importance aux choses
nous avons un méchant c'est dans le sang
c'est le dernier magazine de cette
saison à 2017 2018 c'est une culture est
maintenant terminée mais la culture
revient sur notre antenne à partir du
mois de septembre
merci de nous avoir suivis j'espère que
vous avez apprécié découvrir la culture
sur 50 ans de niveler merci aussi à
toute l'équipe qui m'a accompagné tout
au long de la saison qu'ils soient
journalistes montara réalisateur
infographiste webmaster mais aussi
l'administration
je vous souhaite de passer un très très
bel été
[Musique]